please and gentlemen the world's
greatest escape artist he's gonna fill
the water and then he's gonna go toward
the water see there he goes this animal
Escape Artist is a Giant Pacific octopus
stranded on a boat with only one escape
route if I try to get my wife in a
wedding dress I didn't even see this
tiny hole on the boat how did he manage
to escape through that how does a
massive octopus fit through such a tiny
hole they have something but which is
very special
they have no skeleton at all not
internal not external so they are really
soft but there's one hard part in their
body and this is the beak so but if the
beak fits through any hole the rest of
the body will as well the octopus has
thousands of sensory cells that are able
to taste and smell the environment so
once that tentacle has hit the water
he's alerted that this is the exit route
and he's able to squeeze the entire body
through that tiny little hole and make
it safety okay so why did the octopus
evolve with this incredible ability they
make a pretty good meal for many large
predators the Predators don't have all
that much work to do because there are
no bones so they have to be very very
good at hiding they're really
intelligent they can walk on land and
squeeze through tiny spaces I think
octopi could take over the world